um going back to the
your moz vidal fight i was one like when
you get knocked out like that like what
you so you wake up at some point you
have to learn what happened like is
there even
a memory of it you know like yeah of the
actual knockout the fight or the
knockout or that's the only time i've
ever been
stunned knocked out anything like that
in my whole life
well lawler got you pretty good i would
count lawlessness
no but i i i i in my mind
and yeah who knows that maybe
something's incorrect i remember the
whole thing
i remember the whole thing i remember my
thought process no gaps of
everything that was going on the entire
time you know sure um and with jordan i
told this story i think a couple times
now
uh but you know i i like i know i was
awake
right but i wasn't like my brain wasn't
recording things
the first thing that recorded i opened
my eyes or you know or
i find everything starts clicking again
i saw luke rockhold
i thought [ __ ] luke rockhold got knocked
out i must be in the hospital
you know and then i looked up like
here's my wife and i'm like
[ __ ] am i in the hospital and she's like
yeah and then i remember like
feeling myself and it wasn't like that
sweaty grimy feeling you have like when
you worked hard and then
you know you cool off i'm like [ __ ] it
didn't last very long huh
and i'm like oh my all right what
happened
so that's what that's the first memory
and you're awesome
yeah and then i'm like well hey i feel
fine and then they're like hey the
results are fine and then
uh we left we went to the after party
and then did you watch the video at all
uh yeah i mean i've seen it like a
billion times what was your reaction to
that
your first time seeing it really i don't
remember the first time i saw my wife
don't remember i think he saw how he
tweeted well that sucks
yeah dude you know what pisses me off
expensive sunglasses
because you're going to lose him anyway
so never pay more than 10 bucks for a
pair that's why i buy mine at the gas
station
except they don't ever have the kind
that i'm very particular about i like my
style
right so i made my own these are stevo
sunglasses
and they're only 9.99 at stevo.com and
we got them back in stock
so don't be squinting in the sun getting
wrinkles
go to stevo.com and make your summer fly
with some stevo sunglasses